Це було майже пів століття тому.
Коли Джозефу Байдену було 29 років, вінстав одним з наймолодших політиків, коли-небудь обраних до Сенату Сполучених Штатів.
За успіхом прийшло гірке лихо - за кілька тижнів в автокатастрофі загинули його дружина та донька.
Байден одружився знову.
Та балотувався у 1988 вперше на посаду президента США, а 20 років по тому - ще раз.
Моя бабуся б тут кричала: "Поширюй віру!"
Знову не вийшло. Однак президент Барак Обама зробив Байдена своїм заступником.
Найкращий віце в історії Америки.
Після того, як скінчилося президентство Обами, виглядало так,
що Байден вже ніколи не підніметься на найвищу сходинку влади у США.
Аж поки не з’явився Дональд Трамп.
Ось чому я висуваю сьогодні свою кандидатуру в президенти Сполучених Штатів.
Десятки років політичного досвіду - з таким багажем, переконаний Байден,
він зможе відновити репутацію Америки у світі.
І тому саме зараз настав його час.
Я буду президентом, який проявлятиме солідарність з нашими союзниками та друзями,
а супротивникам дасть зрозуміти, що часи загравання з диктаторами минули.
Протягом 4 років правління Дональда Трампа з його політикою "Америка понад усе"
Вашингтон вибудовував відносини з рештою світу з точки зору зиску для США, а не цінностей.
Прихід до влади Байдена, скоріш за все, призведе до низки змін у зовнішній політиці країни.
Байден, ймовірно, захоче відновити американське лідерство на світовій арені.
І повернути мультилатералізм знову в пріоритети зовнішньої політики США.
Тобто, це може призвести до більшої підтримки НАТО.
По-друге, Байден може обрати більш неприязний тон стосовно Росії.
Під час своєї передвиборчої кампанії він неодноразово викривав Росію, тож ми можемо очікувати ще більше такої риторики.
І по-третє, я гадаю, Байден спробує відродити трансатлантичну співпрацю як традиційну в відносинах з Європою.
Жоден з віцепрезидентів та президентів Сполучених Штатів стільки не відвідував Україну, як Байден.
Шість разів. І це невипадково.
Конфлікт на сході України був у сфері його компетенції як віцепрезидента.
Джо Байден завжди робив сильний акцент на Україні та був зацікавлений нею.
В минулому, за президентства Обами, він був щільно залучений до українських питань.
І подавав гучний голос за більш рішучу позицію США щодо російської агресії в Україні.
Водночас експерти застерігають від завищених очікувань.
Ймовірно, у політиці Сполучених Штатів щодо Києва та Москви не з‘явиться нічого особливо нового.
Гадаю, що з президентом Байденом те, що каже президент, буде більше відповідати політиці, яка проводиться.
Це те, чого ми не побачили під час адміністрації Трампа щодо України та Росії.
Президент України привітав Байдена з перемогою ще у суботу ввечері, як і більшість світових лідерів.
"Україна оптимістично дивиться на майбутнє стратегічного партнерства зі США", - підкреслив Володимир Зеленський.
Натомість Володимир Путін, усупереч заведеній практиці, вітань не надіслав,
у Кремлі пояснили, що чекають офіційних підсумків виборів.
Канцлерці Німеччини Анґелі Меркель, як і десяткам лідерів держав,
для привітання було вже достатньо попередніх результатів, за якими Байден здолав Трампа.
Я щиро вітаю Джо Байдена з обранням 46-м президентом США.
Джо Байден привносить десятиліття свого досвіду у внутрішню та зовнішню політику.
Він знає Німеччину і Європу дуже добре.
Я маю приємні спогади про хороші зустрічі та розмови з ним.
Також Меркель привітала майбутню віцепрезидентку Камалу Харріс.
Цікаво, що Харріс була, власне, конкуренткою Байдена на праймеріз у Демократичній партії.
Однак знялася з виборів через низький рейтинг, після чого Байден запросив її стати його віце.
Харріс - донька іммігрантів з Індії та Ямайки.
Її висунення було важливим розрахунком демократів - показати інше обличчя Америки,
ніж республіканці з їхнім дуетом білих чоловіків Трампа й Пенса,
і заручитись голосами чорношкірих та мігрантів.
Ось ще один прояв характеру Джо:
йому вистачило сміливості зламати один з найміцніших бар’єрів у нашій країні та обрати жінку віцепрезидентом.
І я буду першою жінкою на цій посаді, але не останньою, тому що
кожна маленька дівчинка, яка дивиться на нас сьогодні, бачить, що це - країна можливостей.
Зазвичай політичні погляди віцепрезидентів мають невелике значення.
Однак у випадку з Харріс це інакше.
Байдену на момент інавгурації виповниться 78 років.
Тож, на думку оглядачів, цілком можливо, що він через стан здоров’я не виконуватиме обов‘язки усі чотири роки.
В цьому разі Камала Харріс - їй лише 54 роки - обійме президентську посаду без нових виборів.